what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and
we're gonna be dangerous in this video
uh we're gonna kind of turn this into a
statement to Disney if that really makes
any sense and the reason why is because
Disney is expected to announce that they
haven't already that they have the x-men
and the Fantastic Four and if we're if
we're being honest with ourselves
anybody who believed that Comcast was
going to win the bidding war between
themselves and Disney over the Fox
rights was really kind of kidding
themselves there was no way Disney
wasn't gonna win just because of the
amount of money doesn't he has and the
amount of money they stand to make by
having the x-men and the Fantastic Four
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe that
also includes the Avengers and all those
different guys and so really it's what
the fans wanted is what Disney wanted
and it's worked out in the end for us
and so in reality it really kind of
depends on what direction we go away now
like it's really exciting to see what
what happens but we previously did a
video series where we talked about the
x-men in the MCU which is to say
splitting it in two phases
and that was really based more on if we
had like a phase dedicated to strictly
to the x-men the reality is that that
wouldn't happen you know it'll be a
while before we see the x-men in the MCU
but in in truth we would see them sort
of folded in alongside everybody else
right like we wouldn't you would see it
in addition druggist in a manner akin to
like Thor and Iron Man and Captain
America and stuff like that like it
wasn't like phase 3 was all Captain
America it might as well been but it
wasn't all Captain America I mean so
like phase 2 was all Ironman and so the
results that we're gonna see the x-men
sort of peppered in but the rumor mills
turning out the idea that Marvel and
Disney want to use the Eternals to roll
the x-men over really explain like the
origin of mutants which is a smart move
because one of the things that Fox never
really did was explain the origin of
mutants it was just like they're there
one day
done and like that's it like like yeah
we don't really got an origin of Charles
Xavier we never really got an Origin and
we kind of got an origin of Magneto
to a degree we got an origin for
Wolverine but we didn't really get like
an origin of we're mutants came from and
how they exist they were just suddenly
there one day and so I think that you
know Fox and Disney taking the approach
of giving us an origin for this group
it's pretty significant now the question
becomes how exactly are they going to
give us this origin okay so the reality
of this is that we have to look at the
nature of the Eternals themselves so the
Eternals and Marvel comics are one
really one part of an earth-based
evolution is really far from
like ever better never really evolution
so much as Jean Jean tampering so um
back in the 1970s and then really in
1960s and even go back to 1940s with
Captain America comics you had Jack
Kirby and Joe Simon and Jack Kirby was
the artist Joe Simon was the writer now
of course they created Captain America
fast forward 20 years Jack Kirby is one
of the major leading hands behind the
the formation of Marvel in 1960 it's
really like in Marvel's history you've
had a handful of people who have really
like changed the entire dynamic of the
company from you know for example you
got Stanley Jack Kirby and Steve get
Steve Ditko in the 1960s and then you
had void Thomas in the nineteen
seventies and then you have like a lot
of other writers that came after that
and artists and different things like
that Chris Claremont for the x-men and
Jim Lee for really the x-men after
Claremont Scott Liddell you know a lot
of these guys who have contributed huge
things to the to the various mythos over
the years you know Walt Louise Simonson
for example wrote x-factor if you don't
know what that means it doesn't matter
but they were like a the one-two punch
of the x-factor comics it's they're the
ones who originally made them so when it
comes to when it comes to the Eternals
what had happened was in the early 70s
Jack Kirby didn't really like how he was
being treated at Marvel which is to say
it was basically all the credit going to
Stanley and so what he ended up doing
was basically leaving and he took off
and he went to DC comics at DC Comics he
wanted to create a whole line of
publications called the Fourth World and
they would be totally separate from the
rest of DC so they wouldn't crossover
with Superman or Wonder Woman or Batman
or flash or any of those characters it
would be totally separate and that's
where you've got characters like
Darkseid and the new gods and the
forever people and the anti-life
equation and things like that the issue
was that Jack Kirby was treated pretty
badly at DC so halfway through the
project he quit and went back to Marvel
and so that's why DC rolled New Gods and
you know Darkseid and all those
characters into the main DC line of
comics because they didn't really have a
choice they didn't really know what to
do after Jack Kirby left and so when
Jack Kirby went back to Marvel his idea
was to take his whole fourth world
concept and rolling into Marvel Comics
thus we got the Eternals now the
Eternals were were again one part of a
existing landscape at the time and the
way that Jack Kirby explained this is he
said that at some point and along the
line of Earth's history the planet was
visited by the Celestials and the
Celestials come in what are called hosts
or visited visitations whatever you want
to call the first host was when they
first got here and what they did is they
started looking at all these different
humans it
around Earth and they took a huge chunk
of them and they said we're going to
experiment on your genes now of course
the Celestials you'll recall from
guardians of the galaxy that one guy
with a giant staff that wiped out a
whole planet and the guardians of galaxy
film and yeah whether the name was given
the whole explanation and then you have
I think it's Isan the surgery but anyway
so in this first host the Celestials
visited earth and they said we are going
to meddle with the genes of early humans
and so what they did is they created
three groups you had baseline humans who
didn't show any indication that their
genes had been tampered with
you had the Eternals and who had the
deviance now the deviance were basically
like trolls and monsters well they look
like these terrible horrible ugly
looking things but they basically you
know resided underground now there came
a point no I'm sorry they didn't agree
zone in the ground they resided in
lumeria the capital city of Atlantis and
we'll talk more about that here in a
second and then you had the Eternals who
were really more heavenly beings they
literally look like angels I mean not
all of them had blond hair and blue eyes
but they had like perfect skin and they
have super-strength and they could fly
and they were like the epitome of what
humans were supposed to be and so
fast-forward you know some few hundred
years or something along those lines and
the deviance really the Eternals didn't
really care about anything they were
just hanging in the mountains and doing
whatever they were hippies basically and
the deviance were were like the Morlocks
from HG Wells time machine and so what
ended up happening is the deviance
actually enslaved baseline humans and
forced them to build their cities all
that kind of stuff in in the Atlantean
city of Lemuria and so what happened was
the Celestials came back in the second
host to visit their experiments and to
see how their experiments were
progressing they saw what the deviants
were doing and they were just like the
hell's going on and so they were like
you guys have to stop doing this you
have to stop enslaving baseline humans
the deviance attack the Celestials and
the Celestials initiated what's called
the great Cataclysm and the great
Cataclysm was basically them just like
wiping out everything they sunk Atlantis
and they flooded the world which from
Marvel Comics is where you sort of get
the du-de du-de or Christian ideology of
God flooding the earth that's basically
what happened but Atlantis was sunk all
forms of Technology were lost and
essentially humanity started all over
again which is why if you go and you
read Marvel Comics it looks like
humanity's only been around for ten
fifteen thousand years when in reality
they've been around for a lot longer
it's just that the Celestials forced
everything to be restarted but during
the great Cataclysm the
took off they basically bailed out and
some of them went out to explore the
spaceways explore the Stars and see what
I was out there which is actually
covered and the eternal storyline by
both Jack Kirby and Neil Diamond Neil
Gaiman's Eternals is crazy amazing it's
like a tissues long but it is so badass
um
and then some of the Eternals settled on
Titan on Saturn's moon Titan now this
led to a kind of civil war among the
Eternals on Titan and once a civil war
was over then you ended up having you
know essentially this woman's suisse on
and then another set of the Eternals
left earth again they settled on Titan
she ended up marrying one of the
Eternals who settled on Titan and suisse
on gave birth to Thanos so that's where
like that whole thing really sort of
sorted sort of wraps together hopefully
that light bulbs going off were you just
like oh I see how it's all intertwined
now yes comics are uh mixed in wonderful
world of adventure but back to the
baseline humans so because of the fact
that they never originally showed any
signs of gene tampering there what we
ended up learning was it was basically
kind of a ticking clock like a time
clock that was set and that once this
time clock ended then suddenly these
mutations would start to give rise the
first of these was Selene and Selene is
what we call an external she's a mutant
that is legitimately immortal the caveat
to her is she has to absorb the life
energies of others to keep herself alive
so she's not a true external a true
external would be somebody like Gideon
who was an enemy of x-force and cable
for a long long time but an external is
a mutant who cannot die like they will
they will live forever until you like
decapitate them or something like that
but they'll never die of old age they'll
never die of illness or disease they'll
never die of anything outside of having
their head chopped off so they're not
invulnerable well there's a difference
in Marvel Comics between immortality and
invulnerability you know there are
people who are immortal sometimes Kanak
and I marvel usually uses the word
immortality in the sense that they won't
die of old age or disease that's really
the extent of immortality
invulnerability complements that by
saying not only can they not die of any
kind of disease or old age but no one
can harm them so they're basically
beyond reproach we're just like
apocalypse you know or somebody like
that kind of depending on who's writing
the story okay I want to talk about that
for a second take Wolverine for example
like one of the big misconceptions is
that Wolverine is an external that's not
true
Wolverine would die but let's say for
example that Wolverine never had Adam
antium bonded to his bones and that
meant that he would go forward with just
insane healing factor like any muscle in
the body the healing factor would
eventually burn out it might be in two
thousand years or ten thousand years but
eventually it would burn out and he
would just die of old age so he's not
inherently immoral he wouldn't live
forever whether or not he had a healing
factor doesn't really matter there but
the fact remains you know beating into
this idea of the you know getting back
to a baseline humans when Celine's
powers first manifested she just kind of
roamed the earth and that was like ten
thousand years BC you know ten thousand
BC and the Hyborian age I think it was
about five thousand years later
apocalypse rose and apocalypse started
you know traveling around the world and
basically forcing people to worship Him
as a god and different things like that
and then like over the course of you
know that next 5,000 years leading to
the Year Zero essentially um what you
ended up having were like various
mutants here and there who would pop up
occasionally it wasn't until the 1960s
it like suddenly you had this huge
explosion of mutants and even a little
bit before the nineteen sixties I
probably round the 1930s or 40s is when
you started having this huge explosion
of mutants that's one of the reasons why
the event of weapons Plus was launched
and project one or project rebirth or
Captain America was created in order to
combat the mutant threat that's kind of
a fun fact a lot of people don't know
Captain America was originally created
in the Marvel Universe to stop the
meeting threat World War two was a
testbed it was a test to see how well he
would perform when he was going against
like insurmountable odds and then from
there he would be the first in a long
line of super soldiers that would wipe
out essentially that would be like
humanity's police force against a Newton
population that all goes back to the
very very very early stages of project
wide awake really before it was called
wide awake but it goes back to the early
stages of project wide awake and then
what would eventually become operation
zero tolerance and all that kind of
stuff
burning that's been for a long time
folks so much knowledge up here about
the excellent it's crazy but unless
that's that would be the origin of
mutants now here's the problem that you
run into the problem that you run into
in Marvel Comics and that you would run
into in the movies is if this is the
origin of the x-men and mutants have
existed for so long that how comes no
one no one's heard about them like why
hasn't anybody heard about Charles
Xavier or Magneto or or any of these
guys well the answer to that comes in
the origin of mutants in the Ultimate
Universe and that's what I think Marvel
is gonna do I think that's what Marvel
and DC you're gonna do because it's the
easiest way to do things
you basically blend both universes
together what you say is that the
you'll still modify the genes of early
man and they basically gave way to what
would become mutants it's just that
mutants weren't discovered until
Wolverine now the way this worked in
Marvel Comics and and and and the way
this works in the Marvel movies is they
kind of shifted things up of it right
like most of the Marvel movies in fact
pretty much all the Marvel movies borrow
heavily from the Ultimate Universe
there's a couple of exceptions like
Captain America being the first super
soldier that comes from the main Marvel
Universe but in the Ultimate Universe
Samuel Jackson Nick Fury was the
original super soldier and then after
Nick Fury came Steve Rogers Captain
America but during the EMAs Ultimate
Universe origin when it comes to the
mutant population what ended up
happening is when Nick Fury was created
or when he was given a Super Soldier
Serum that was done by the United States
in Canada James Howlett was given the
same Super Soldier Serum the problem
with this was that when they started
going through and analyzing his genes
what they realized is there was like a
gene that if it was activated would
grant people powers and so they
activated his gene which gave him a
healing factor and then adamantium was
bonded to his bones and so following
that they basically prayed this kind of
substance that was spread throughout the
world and all the mutants power mute and
power started waking up so those of you
guys who read it in humans or anybody
who does but those of you guys who read
in humans or saw agents of shield
imagine what you saw an agents of shield
pertaining to the mutant population
that's basically what would happen and
that's what happened in the Ultimate
Universe and it was a super quick and
easy way to introduce mutants and say
now we got the x-men like in and all
that kind of good stuff and it worked
really really well but that's how you
rolling it that's literally what you do
you give the celestial origin with
regards to the Eternals but then you say
something happened somewhere along the
line like Steve Rogers Captain America
dies during infinity war or during
Avengers four and so now after his death
it's like a mad race by all these
countries to create their own versions
of quote-unquote Captain America and in
the process that discovered James
Howlett they activate his gene he pops
up as Wolverine they spread the
substance around the world and something
we can start popping up everywhere
there's a lot of ways to pull this off
and a lot of ways to make it work but
that seems to be the simplest one so
that's kind of my statement to Disney
hopefully it works I mean I mean I'm a
guy who talks about comic books on
YouTube I'm there's no reason you should
listen to me or no reason you should
have to listen to me but I've also been
reading x-men for a long time so I have
a lot of knowledge that I can bring to
the table but you're also dealing with
directly with Marvel and
on the accident - so anyway hopefully
this gets taken into consideration by
slim body I have no idea and yeah if you
are new here - comments explained make
sure you ask the sub button to become
part of the rod core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]